colombia tendrá un presidente ex
guerrillero gustavo petro y una
vicepresidenta lideresa ambiental y
afrodescendiente francia márquez es
precisamente la primera vicepresidenta
afrodescendiente de la historia de
colombia y también será el primer
gobierno de izquierda de la historia de
colombia para ello han necesitado la
máxima votación nunca vista cosechada
por un candidato en este caso gustavo
petro que en su discurso ha agradecido
el voto masivo de jóvenes y mujeres
también ha solicitado a la fiscalía
liberar a los jóvenes detenidos en el
paro nacional del año 2021 que empezó el
28 de abril y que son las protestas más
grandes de la historia o de décadas de
colombia también ha hablado de un
acuerdo nacional en el que ha invitado a
su contrincante a rodolfo hernández
también a álvaro uribe el ex presidente
y también ha hablado para callar todas
las dudas que tienen de que pueda
convertir a colombia en una web
venezuela de desarrollar el capitalismo
ya fundamentados
en tres ejes en la paz en la justicia
social y en la justicia ambiental y para
acabar también ha enviado un mensaje a
la región
incluyendo también a eeuu de realizar
una transición energética para vivir
sabroso que ha sido uno de los lemas de
la campaña terminando con el grito de
libertad gustavo petro y francia-
márquez tomarán posesión el próximo 7 de
agosto